Even the power of all six Infinity Stones
combined has its limits.
So declared Avengers: Endgame screenwriters
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely in
a recent sitdown with the New York Times,
addressing the heart-wrenching death of one
of the MCU's longest-tenured characters.
Fair warning: we’ll be discussing spoilers
from here on.
On a quest to the past to recover the Soul
Stone from the planet Vormir before it was
acquired by Thanos, Clint Barton and Natasha
Romanoff find themselves faced with the same
conundrum as the Mad Titan in Avengers: Infinity
War.
To possess the stone, you must lose that which
you love.
In a heartbreaking illustration of the pair's
bond, they end up actually fighting each other,
each determined to be the one to go over the
cliff to their deaths so that the other can
complete the mission.
In the end, the Black Widow prevails and plunges
to her doom on the planet's rocky beach, leaving
a distraught Hawkeye wailing to the heavens
with the glowing stone in hand.
The Times asked Markus and McFeely: Why did
Black Widow have to die?
Bruce Banner used the power of the Tony Stark-built
Infinity Gauntlet to bring back all of the
heroes who perished in Infinity War's Decimation.
Why could he not bring her back, as well?
"This is monsters and magic and nothing we
were ever trained for."
The writers offered a little insight into
their thought process in dealing with the
death of a founding Avenger, the only woman
on the original team.
McFeely says:
But do the other characters and the audience
get a chance to mourn such a central character?
McFeely says that was a huge challenge for
the writing duo.
Markus adds:
The answer lies in the very nature of the
Soul Stone, and the trade that it demands.
McFeely makes it clear that bringing back
Natasha would mean giving up the stone.
Apparently, if Banner had concentrated with
single-minded focus on resurrecting Romanoff,
he may have sealed the fate of literally everyone
else by giving up the Soul Stone, negating
the noble sacrifice she had made.
The writers also revealed that an early version
of the script had Hawkeye, not Black Widow,
making the sacrifice, but the impassioned
plea of a member of Endgame's crew changed
their minds.
McFeely said,
"We're still friends, right?"
"Depends on how hard you hit me."
In the MCU's timeline, Earth's Mightiest Heroes
will be Black Widow-less going forward.
But that won't stop Mighty Marvel from looking
into the past: after being promised for years,
Black Widow is finally getting her own solo
film, which is currently in production and
will focus on the future Avenger's early years
and recruitment by S.H.I.E.L.D.
The film's official synopsis reveals that
the flick will take place 15 years after the
fall of the Soviet Union, which would put
it right around 2006, before the Iron Man
armor was even a gleam in Tony Stark's eye.
Johansson will reprise her role, and the flick
also boasts the red-hot Florence Pugh, David
Harbour, and Rachel Weisz among its cast.
Aussie director Cate Shortland is set to helm
the picture from a script by Jac Schaeffer,
who contributed to the screenplay for Captain
Marvel and will run the Vision and Scarlet
Witch limited series for Disney-Plus.
So, while the only true family she's ever
known may have seen the last of Romanoff,
the viewing audience has not.
Black Widow is expected to be the first film
of the MCU's Phase 4, which raises another
intriguing question: how will its events figure
into whatever grand, overarching narrative
Marvel Studios has planned next?
We can't wait to find out, and to see Scarlett
Johansson suit up as our favorite Russian
superspy at least one more time.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Avengers
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.